hi klickum hi Bushido meine Frage an
dich ist wie die Zusammenarbeit mit
Moses P entstanden ist finde ich ein
sehr interessantes Projekt und sonst
wüns ich dir viel Erfolg mit deinem Film
und dem neuen Album der der Mann der
damals auch schon Rödelheim gemacht hat
der der Mann der Xia NAD entdeckt hat
der Sabrina setlo entdeckt hat Kassandra
stetin zusammen mit glashhaus der jetzt
praktisch eine neue glashhaus
Kombination mit Peppa hat und ich war
schon immer großer Fan von ihm und auch
von der Musik die er gemacht hat und ich
habe ih dann irgendwann angefragt und äh
über die Schwester von Sabrina Setlur
die hatt immer noch dort bei 3P arbeitet
und wir haben dann einfach mal den
Kontakt hergestellt ich habe in Moses
telefoniert wir haben uns unterhalten
und dann war für uns eigentlich schon
recht früh klar dass wir bei der gute
miteinander auskommen und dass wir uns
dann hinsetzen und ein Song produzieren
und moses hat den Song auch selber
produziert also mit Martin ha zusammen
aber das da habe ich so als Produzent
praktisch meine Finger von gelassen und
ist ein unglaublich schöner Song
geworden Peppa singt unglaublich schön
ich habe guten wor gekickt und Moses und
Martin haben auch einen sehr schönen
Song produziert und deswegen sage ich
persönlich noch mal dankeeschön an Moses
an die ganze Bande von 3P und es ist ein
super Song geworden danke dafür